تحصرنا 22 يوم تاريخ
19/12 الساعه 10 ونص تقريبا الصبح طلعت
اكلم بابا بابا له ست سنين مسافر فطلعت قط
ارسال وكانت دبابه موجوده بالي انا شفتها
وكان حجمها كثير كبير كان طوابق وكانت
اختي معي قلت لها اطلعي برا على الصالون
عبل ما انزل ستارت المطبخ بلاش صفونا لانت
بابا كان حجمها كثير كبير فانا طلعت نزلت
الستاره وحطيت الكرسي بين الثلاجه
والغساله وادوب قعدت ل لهم قصون قدت ماما
على ركبها وقدتم عني
الشظايا وانا ما كنت حاسه برجلي بالمره
وحملوني ونزلوني على دارنا ما كانش ولا في
اي اضاه طبيه عم وشاف الليفه اللي بالليف
فيها الصحور السلكه دوا جلي وكلور مسكهم
وصار ليف لي في رجلي ورجلي وبطر لي رجلي
بدون بين وبدون اي شيء بالدار وحط سطل
تحتي وقعدوا يطبوا كشافات عشان يشوف
الشريان وانا كنت بس احكي الحمد لله واقرا
قران والحمد لله ما حسيت كثير من فضل ربنا
نزل علي الصبر بس كان طبعا في وجع والمنظر
والصدمه ورجلي الشمال منظرها برضه ورجلي
هي دندله هيك
ومقطوعه نفسيه كيف انه بدي اقول لبابا
وبابا لحاله بره في
الغربه